If you're a web developer,
you've almost certainly
used XMLHttpRequest.
But without a library wrapping
XHR, it's a pain in the butt.
It requires a bunch
of setup, needs
calls to both open and send,
and worst of all, the name.
Why does it even
have XML in the name?
Chances are, you didn't
use it to transfer XML.
So now we have a new
modern design API
for network requests, Fetch.
[BALL  BOUNCING]
The new Fetch API
makes this much easier
with a simple, cleaner
API that separates
the request from the
response and uses
Promises to avoid the
hassles of callbacks.
So let's go Fetch some data.
The Fetch API is
pretty easy to use.
Simply call Fetch and provide
the URL that you want to Fetch
and optionally any parameters
that you need to provide.
Fetch then returns a Promise
with the response object
that contains details
about the response,
such as the status code,
headers, and other metadata.
Plus, it provides access
to the response stream
with an understanding of
what type of data it is.
For example, since
my data is JSON,
I'll ask for response.json,
which returns
a Promise to get that data.
If you haven't guessed
by now, Promises
are integral to the
way that Fetch works.
If you're unfamiliar
with Promises,
check out this post
on HTML5 Rocks.
One of the neat things that
you can do with Promises
is to chain them.
For Fetch, this means
that you can share logic
across different Fetch requests.
Instead of checking the
status of a response
with an inline function, I'll
create a separate function
that checks the status
code and returns a Promise.
I'll do the same thing
to get the JSON object
from the response stream.
Now, I can simplify the
Fetch request quite a bit.
I'll make the Fetch,
check the status code
to make sure I got a
200 OK, get the JSON,
and then handle the
result. If anything
goes wrong along the way, I
can catch the error and deal
with it.
In addition to the
request URL, you can also
pass Fetch a set of options.
With the options object,
I can set the method used,
add HTTP headers, set
the body of the request,
add credentials, even control
how cross-domain requests are
handled.
For example, to use Fetch to
post the results of some user
input along with
an OAuth token, I
would use "method" colon
"post," "headers" colon
"Authorization," followed
by some ugly string,
and "body" colon the
data that I want to post.
Making cross-domain
requests with Fetch
uses the same policies
as XMLHttpRequest,
verifying that the
correct CORS headers are
present before
returning the Promise.
It sets the response
dot type to CORS,
indicating it was a successful
cross-domain request.
But if the correct
headers aren't set,
then the Fetch
will fail, and you
won't be able to
access the status
or read the data returned.
I can also tell the
browser specifically
how I want it to handle
cross-domain requests with one
of four mode options.
I can set mode colon
same-origin to ensure
that only requests made to
the same origin are possible.
Anything else is rejected.
I can set mode colon
cors to allow requests
for assets on the same origin
and on other origins, which
return the appropriate headers.
I can force preflight checks
to always occur with mode colon
cors-with-forced-preflight.
But there's also a mode no-cors
to get data from a server that
doesn't support CORS.
But this results in
an opaque response.
You won't be able to
read the data returned
or view the status
of the request.
This might seem odd.
But when caching results
in a service worker,
this is a very helpful feature.
There you go.
Fetch is pretty easy to use.
There are still a
few gotchas, though,
that you need to be aware of.
Like all new features, it's
not available everywhere yet,
but support is growing quickly.
So be sure to use feature
detection to see if it's there.
If not, you can
use the polyfill.
The other big gotcha is that you
can't cancel a Fetch request.
But it is in the spec,
so it should land
at some point in the future.
So go give Fetch a shot, and
save yourself a few callbacks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]